every night 3 a.m. on the dot she leaves
the front street are the smell of
alcohol and cigarettes stuck to that
gorgeous dress she's wearing before she
gets in her flat top to head home she
does the same thing every night she goes
up to the roof and stares at the city
it's always right around this time that
I'm getting off my shift in no ways
right around this time that I see her
the Dame the goddess it's like she's
just waiting up here for me every night
and every night I'd deny her desires
but not this night I had a few too many
earlier and was feeling the
uncharacteristically courageous I slowly
approached her my heart feeling like a
cantaloupe in my chest I tried not to
but I snuck a look at her damn she knew
what she was doing what was it about
this girl suddenly my legs turned
towards her on their own I don't
remember telling them to do that to my
surprise she did the same then I got my
first real look at her
whatever she was I wanted more of it we
began moving closer like some kind of
otherworldly force was drawing us nearer
she reached up and put her arms around
me and it wasn't until now that I
realized I was completely calm my
heartbeat had slowed
I felt perfect it was then that I
realized this girl she wasn't like the
other broads she was a name to kill for
sin city a dame to kill for is directed
by Robert Rodriguez and co-directed by
Frank Miller based off of his source
material this movie sees the return of
Mickey Rourke as Marv
we have newcomers Joseph gordon-levitt
and Eva Green as well as Josh Brolin and
Ray Liotta we also have rosario Dawson
and Jessica Alba returning as well as
Bruce Willis tons of people in this
movie now I'm a big fan of the first Sin
City I thought it was a very visually
interesting film with a lot of really
cool stories as well so I was excited to
see this new film but the fact that it
was pushed back so much kind of had me
worried but at the same time it could
just be they're trying to improve their
movie which I think they did because sin
city a dame to kill for is a pretty damn
good movie and I had a lot of fun
watching it not only is this a visually
arresting movie I mean it just glues you
to your seat with it's incredible
visuals but there are some really good
stories mixed throughout as well and
that's one of the best parts about these
Sin City films is the stories I'm a big
fan of film noir I love film noir if you
couldn't tell from my opening skit intro
and that's one of the things I love
about these Sin City films is that they
have that Pulp Fiction a grimy
grittiness to them where they just feel
dirty and seedy and under worldly and
smoke and mist and all that shit
style in the room you can smell it you
can feel it that's what I love about
these Sin City movies and they
definitely pull it off again for a
second time is this as good as the first
Sin City I wouldn't say so largely
because I found that although the
stories were still fun and enjoyable to
watch it didn't have the same emotional
punch as the first film and did not feel
as visceral it didn't feel as
hard-hitting really as the first one
that being said I did have a really good
time watching this movie and I found all
the stories interesting despite the fact
that some of them had a few sideline
plots that I didn't really feel was
necessary particularly something
involving Christopher Meloni and Jeremy
Piven which really in retrospect just
feels like a little addition that isn't
really necessary to the film or the plot
it just feels like it's there because
it's there it is great to see Mickey
Rourke kicking ass again as Marv he's
one of the best parts of this movie
Bruce Willis doesn't have a hue
mungus role in this movie I would relate
to his role to his role in The Sixth
Sense if you've seen The Sixth Sense you
know what I mean now one of my
complaints with the first film was that
Jessica Alba well beautiful and amazing
to look at wasn't really that strong of
a performer her performance was very
OneNote in my opinion that is not the
case at all in this film her character
is much more dark she's very interesting
a lot of stuff is going on in her head
because of events that happened in the
first film which makes for some very
interesting psychological twists with
her character I thought she did a much
better job in this one I know the great
addition to this movie is Joseph
gordon-levitt as a very suave and very
lucky poker player who keeps getting in
over his head I really liked his
performance in this movie as well as his
short story one of the things I loved
about this movie is that Joseph
gordon-levitt has now come full circle
since angels in the outfield he made Don
John with Tony Danza who was the pitcher
and angels in the outfield and in this
movie he gets a scene with Christopher
Lloyd who was al in angels in the
outfield it's perfect my childhood is
now complete I suppose my main problem
with this movie is actually the title
character Eva Green's character a dame
to kill for I didn't really find myself
too invested in her story and she has
one of the most fleshed out and long
stories in the film and a lot of it
seemed very predictable and more over
the top than usual for Sin City although
it is very nice to see her once again in
a Frank Miller adaptation this year
where she does not mind showing off her
skills all in all sin city a dame to
kill for was a very fun time of the
movies it looks great it sounds great
some of the stories are really cool it's
not quite as good as the first one
though it doesn't have that emotional
punch that the first one had behind it
the stories felt a little bit more
secondary to the more primary stories of
the first one I'm gonna give the film a
B I do think that fans of Frank Miller
are gonna have a good time as well as
fans of the first film you guys are
gonna find some stuff to enjoy so what
are your thoughts on the first Sin City
as well as the new one if you've seen it
yet thanks as always for watching guys
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes